traditionalism is valued in women
because it shows how she values herself
and her body if you indiscriminately
give your body away to everyone it's not
special anymore what makes anyone think
a hoe would make moral or sound choices
for their man and their kids or not
divorce him that's true can I ask you a
question wait so if that's true
no but then do you know the funny thing
is right one pose can be very smart a
lot of hoes are very intelligent you
don't give a [ __ ] yeah
all you give a [ __ ] about is is sex and
loyalty and the whole will probably give
you sex and she can lie about being
loyal if a woman tells you her body
count is zero and she's a virgin that's
that's what you're gonna believe so yes
a matter it's stupid they know if you've
been single a long time
they know if you're over a certain age
like I mean I I hear I hear I hear guys
like that they like I'm friends with a
lot of guys in these spaces that give
dating advice to men and they said yeah
if a girl says she's over 25 and a
virgin don't believe her if she's been
saying that's not true
five-year-olds that are virgins okay
okay well they could say that but I
don't know no no it's not if she says
she's a virgin it's if she says she has
three or two bodies that's the magic
number that's that's the automatic go-to
for lies it's it's how they try to sound
realistic hey in my experience that's
that's the that's the number that
they've been they've been going after I
think you can tell if somebody is
experienced or not yeah especially if
they're gonna sleep with you like the
first time you meet you're like well if
you're doing this with me you're doing
this with like other guys yeah she did
bodies my ass am I that perfect
I didn't even do anything I didn't even
try with you if a girl makes you wait
six to 12 months and you've had to meet
her family and you've had to actually be
in a serious relationship that whole
time that girl is either a virgin or has
a body count of like one that is a very
modest serious girl but anything short
of that she's been at least around a
little yeah I mean the way I look at it
is like I mean even if you kiss a girl
at a club if you just meet her and she's
already making out with you brother
you're not that special you know what I
mean like you're not that special
you can have a good time and you might
really like her and end up dating her
but she's you're but yeah you know what
I mean what type of virgins you know
um
[Laughter]
I really want to know what vibrator you
recommend to your friends like the group
of people that subscribe to this that
because I know there's a favorite Brands
I know they have a group chat and
they're like yo the the Maestro [ __ ]
monster a few thousand that's [ __ ]
way better than these men yeah that's
true okay yeah JavaScript
we've gotten to this point you don't
know how to use a mouse or something
when you're done I don't know I don't I
don't like that we've gotten to this
point where men and women just talk
about this really personal crust stuff
so openly that a guy can just say uh
what brand of you know vibrator do you
do you use and everyone's like you know
no like this is something for women to
talk about with women and men go have
your male locker room talk why do why
does why do we have to talk about that
together it's just so classless don't
talk like that it's a personality do you
see men having different value in terms
of their romantic potential to you so do
you see some that have higher some have
lower you don't know them personally but
you seem some is higher and lower but
not every and not every man is seen as
equal and your eyes are worse of course
um to be honest I am somebody who really
just I can it's mainly just personality
no no I'm saying outside of personality
so I'm like for example like if if a
Matchmaker came to you said we've got 10
guys this is what it is on paper some
you would rate higher than others
wouldn't you based on what you're
looking I would probably rate bombs low
okay yeah exactly okay so you rate guys
at different values right do you
understand that men do the same for
women yeah of course okay so do you
think courting is deserving of the
highest value woman although I'm higher
value he sees her the mortgage I'm just
asking a question no yeah I can do you
think the higher value he sees a woman
the more he should call her
probably yeah okay but the funny thing
is right so there's some women to a
guy's eyes right if he sees courting is
reserved for the highest value woman in
his eyes yeah what's wrong there'll be
some women that he sees that's not worth
quoting yeah definitely of course okay
that's all we're saying no I know when
people say she's for the streets they
don't wanna exactly I
doesn't change the fact that a hoe
whatever you define as a hoe
is deserving of quoting and she will be
quoted by someone who she might not be
quoted by you but trust me
yeah
man than most virgins no no no probably
more premium men than most people okay
let's for the sake of the conversation
to find a hoe with somebody that has sex
on the first date she is being courted
up until the moment where she has sex on
the first date and then the courtship is
over so yes she's right they're going to
be courted but they're not going to have
real true courtships where people are
falling in love and getting to know each
other and a man is fulfilling his
natural instinct to slowly pray uh you
know I pray as a negative word but you
know really hunt and find the right
woman and win her he wants to win a
woman and if she just jumps into his lap
okay that was fun he's gonna you know
play with his prize but then he's gonna
go find someone that he can actually win
that can be the long-term prize common
based mom W okay okay so so you're right
on some level hoes do a very good job of
hiding it a lot of the time and they do
end up getting married a lot of the time
but the issue and I've asked a lot of
older people this it's also
statistically proven that the more
bodies a woman has the less happy she
like the less likely she has to actually
be happy in the relationship and the the
percentage of it be going to [ __ ] is
higher it makes sense has been proven
yeah you read that should I look it up
right now yeah while you're looking like
I've asked people like in their 40s 50s
like what happens to the hoes they get
married eventually they say yeah but
they're the first divorced it's funny
yeah so they the same thing I want to go
back to that that the hoes get married
but they're the first to get divorced oh
yeah
well they're more likely to rate their
marriages happy after 10 years
because that's that's a big question are
they actually even another thing is
women will compare every guy like if she
sleeps with like a hundred guys she's
gonna like compare all of them to you
you know what I mean so she's constantly
like looking at competition and [ __ ]
like that but men don't do that I mean
men do that they don't compare like
you're gonna tell me that when a man is
in a relationship with a woman even if
he really loves her that he's not
looking back on the CEO of women he's
had before and doing comparisons
I think I think they are I think it may
have a different effect I think it's
that's what I think I think that's what
I meant to say is that it has a
different effect I'm a little maybe I'm
a little woozy right now and happy
I believe women so if we ask them and
they say they're happy
do you not believe women so this is
false I don't say no my question would
be seriously are they actually happy
after but we believe women here so yeah
if they say they're happy that's really
good so let's just talk about I still
don't think I've got an answer to a
question though which question so it
sound it sounds to me at this stage that
I know you're speaking on behalf of
women but it sounds that's what you said
but it sounds like no you did not I'm
speaking on behalf of myself
you've said that you're speaking on
behalf of women it sounds to me like
you're speaking more on behalf of
yourself I've never said I was speaking
last one but so let's go back to my
original question okay you said every
woman deserves to be quiet okay yes now
if a man my own opinion right but if a
man but you've also said courtship
obviously being dating without sex but
you've also said that women and men can
date and you've you just agreed recently
that a man a man and a woman can it can
lead to a relationship if a man and a
woman has sex uh while they're dating so
why the [ __ ] is a man gonna waste all of
it why is the man going to waste all of
those all of those resources that time
and energy on calling you with no
guarantee of six at the end when you can
just date you have six at the same time
and get the same loyalty and sustainable
at the end so he can date someone else
and have sex because if you're gonna
Court me we're not gonna have sex
because I'm not gonna just sleep with
you you've just gone back on your
statement yeah but then like why why
wouldn't he just I'm trying to answer
your question he's saying why have you
gone back earlier because you said that
someone can date you and have sex but
you're saying that's the difference
in general okay
you you can't date me and just have sex
and it and I will hope that one day it
releases the relationship right that
can't happen respectfully respectfully
forget you for a second I'm talking
that's why that's why people yeah for
women in general yeah you can date and
it can lead to a relationship for other
women but the reason why I don't think
that's right is because that can is not
a hundred percent so I don't think it's
right
it's not 100 that's going to lead to a
relationship to marriage yeah
oh God bless you my fault you dating is
Gonna Leave You 100 to marriage
I'm not gonna just let you take me out
and sleep
but at the same time it's also not a
guarantee that a man will get six at the
end of courtship so it sounds like you
want to have your cake and eat it well
yeah
because a manship is it marriage or just
dating courtship is dating and it really
has the word itself has a really
old-fashioned connotation to it it was
literally when a man would come to the
door and ask a woman's father if he
might Court his daughter which in the
beginning meant sitting on the front
porch with a with a lemonade and just
talking to her you know now it means you
know going out on a date and stuff but
it was it it has a really sweet
connotation and innocent connotation
back from a day when um women were more
self-respecting and treated their bodies
with greater value he puts in more
effort and should be risking more
because men need women more than women
what men need women more than women need
men I'm not even listening to her
anymore she's boring she is boring and I
thought it was weird
you just were saying that this dude
you're saying is man spreading bro he's
sitting alone in a chair gee I actually
I I listen stuff I can't you know how I
feel about the word man spreading I
think it's so silly it's just a
ridiculous term but I don't like how
he's sitting he could be sitting more
like a gentleman unless he's got a
watermelon between his legs there is no
reason to sit slumped down like that
with his legs improper body language he
just looks he looks he could have a
little more classes
you don't want to you'll hold out from
sex you'll hold out you'll hold out but
you expect you this you expect this you
expect this but now today like Society
women just give out sex and so that's
why I said the value of sexism and the
value of
the point of the matter is you're
talking about why women should be quoted
and the whole debate is why women
shouldn't be basically like because
we're not deserving of it or what type
of woman should be
and you're saying you want to be and
that's fine but that we're talking about
Society about women
okay what I just got out of that is that
women now overall don't deserve to be
courted the way they used to and I don't
know if it's about deserving or not but
it is about you you have to remember
what courting was about it was about
earning and gaining a winning a woman's
affections but now you know that you
don't have to why court if you just are
going to get the affection after buying
or a couple of apple martinis what's the
[ __ ] point you know so she's right
you know if you're going to be a high
value woman take your time and give
yourself to only men you know who who
really value you in return but otherwise
you know if you just want sex guys just
go ahead go get the girl that only
requires one or two apple martinis and
have a great time every weekend that's
all it's fine but let's not pretend that
this whole free sex and being a [ __ ]
thing is working for women because it's
not
gone
[Music]
[Music]